no it's a found footage horror movie
we're getting ready to go to the camping
trip and I can't hold the camera still
oh hey what's up Tim Lucas here we're
about to go on a hug
what's up guys I'll be the only one that
survived if I'm holding the camera the
beta I ask you to be hit hey guys things
are on the way to the fight Oh God looks
like we got banana
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
the car for your McDonald still zooming
in with the cancer
[Music]
[Music]
I do not have a wallet by my side
yes my Thomas today we're driving a
Silent Hill you see how I do
[Music]
when the audio Eid launched they have a
dubbing something media refers to all
Wow literally low-hanging clouds I'll
show you something you're a 10 mile
drive from sanity the gas station thank
God that's our road trip destination
after all this time how are you have a
special youtube channel that ye [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I like making quality content that takes
time and seatbelt and and doesn't even
get made in five minute rate there's a
pub in Bear one look out it's a bear hey
can I see your credit card directly on
camera and how much is gas expected
thank you George Washington what a
[ __ ] people and like I said that
instead of Obama this time okay wait
what I was hoping you'd Nana oh no
nobody's over okay I saw it in my hearts
I with my Sharingan will give this loan
gasoline covered carrot I got a there
you got that process give me $25 a carat
pretty first Carrie quick it's $5 x-ray
to eat there now just on it what it's
called Shawn she wanted it's got a lot
of things on it it's on the hospital I
don't have money
it's almost word a gas station said what
are you volume up because you guys keep
telling me to point the camera you don't
know if you don't have money to give me
proof of us eat that carrot what
what's the point of any fish let's walk
home that's still doable it's just not
working all right Shawn will you push
the car I'll stand on top and filming
star
this is what we're we're really into it
for audience filming the inside of a gas
station that's what's important
not not wilderness I thought we are at
cell thanks a lot water with our pets I
said hopefully then you just walked off
hey I'm filming I'll hold it will good
idea health care all right hey since I
don't have any money can one of you guys
like by me do you know them I know I
have sacrament i water rights some
someone by me I have food someone by me
happiness nah I don't know all these
YouTube money can do that
tell me what are you
Oh David you gotta find a CI motor oils
yeah I just pour that in your tank it'll
go great for generations this is the
different country looking for a balloon
gas station feminine products they are
too close to the cornerstone of society
with hey guys can some oh really left
all right
well another time then iron man's metal
thing hey guys why is David leaving
without us
no Terry happened made you look I mean I
can't even see him in my field of view
I'll sing my knees
oh thank you that whole dollar
I could I could buy it like baby you
miss out because some of it includes the
door yet explain the situation
so nobody be jerky we're opening a beef
jerky so what's going on with the gas
well I got again
okay what's gonna unwrap it
the difference is they're giving him
like 0.5 of an inch of water you'll
awesome you got to give him more than
that we good leaving unwrapped your own
media we that was exhibit your just now
I'm good no no I beg an expert no I
there's drool on them I know I it's your
drool and now he's just rough it up
against my face I don't want your meat
stick well that's all my to talk also
ours not gum he'll watch on meat stick
either way does anyone have gum trust
him
yes right there I stopped off I uh I
wanted to go I deserve that
boy if the audience doesn't think I'm an
annoying prick but already they're gonna
good logging yeah thank you talking to
we don't have subscribers from the top
of this glim Jim is going to okay that I
won't be okay no no it gets stuck under
his brake and then we run out of gas so
we're just rolling why does no one have
gas the wrong you almost hit that red
thing me we're gonna Brown gas driving
in a circle we stop like right from the
car annual all right anyway we do it
yeah again use this dollar when I give
your oak again who is going to happen
anyway hmm but you're wrong opinion I
always get really nervous at gas
stations because I feel like I'm going
to get stabbed why even if it's like a
really high-class gas station what the
hell the hydrogenation 7-eleven yeah
it's just gas it is a pillar of our
society it was a biggest tragedy in
American history now I'm good
you [ __ ] okay shove it in your mouth
like you like it
yours oh here you go mister viewer mr.
Vieau this is no gender [ __ ] race on
all right oh god okay go you get as a
wreck I've got my alt account things yes
up nah
what is it you and Shelly fluid in my
mouth
finally food Xavier the title is videos
shoving things in my mouth gone wrong
almost night here's 600 hours of
evidence that you're a bad parent you
put it
online snow but with reason you have a
Zoolander car well it was leaving
Lightning McQueen I'm gonna Lightning me
kill myself
I said a mean to curse out
well we don't know how they died but we
do know some geeky cap that we have
video evidence of just about everything
except the car accident the organs
people enjoy our mood even black right
to sex me a thumbs up there's a black
thumb though you change the skin
Glenwood you can see how people cream
color
I'm good thing at the older beginner
you're safe the flame yeah that's what I
saw a psyche what's the difference
between me and you
oh I saw human fingers David kicker
monkey make a mess everywhere car are
you eating the chicken Ron still bastard
a trailer park surrounded by trees the
cockroach a domestic domiciles society
may fall but the trailer parks will
subside we're in Colorado Springs
goddammit every time I film now you're
getting fitted which support left i
before i anna anna has her own youtube
channel go subscribe I know she's know
you need your features box your best
shot and I don't she's on your time baby
sha Shan you upload 10-second overwatch
clips and no audio if I measure yeah
good ticket if something where's the
beach but with our knife hey guys we got
my four-year-old half of my plate
I'll get another one sandy of eternally
we live in a free state
[Music]
[Music]
you should think of credit yeah I know
but I think he won't get 170 feelings I
would live here [ __ ] look at all these
would you live here yeah if you w do do
you do
what's up grace on you mean that the
Internet is not a good Wow
what hell is that that's a haunted house
that's all [ __ ] hold it out where you
can all right natural TOA basement okay
man I wish my camera was better so he
could see this like this they gorgeous
look at the mountain it's over 5,100
it's a kick-ass pool looking on good
thing I live a crippling fear only along
with like a really awesome little picnic
area yeah nothing has this really
old-timey feel to it
the thing will be here my devices cool I
got that out cause we got to cure son it
was six six
when did you purchase it Wow hey
Nicholas am I trying to work will is
your fear of heights getting any better
as we get further sir
look at this crazy valley gonna be one
of those girls know she's driving a Jeep
because you stole it no no I mean like
those people who are like I'll only date
guys who drive Jeeps
how are you talking about I swear to god
that's a thing funny it's like you big
big girls to dress up for spider-man in
the bedroom not I'm going to [ __ ]
murder will with that hatchet later but
I'm gonna say yeah anything David
passionately are you going to steal from
David yes I got movie it's a nice [ __ ]
who wants to have a lightsaber fight on
that
[Music]
that's some nice river you got there
and yeah we'll freaking out but nature
is beautiful my friend yes that man oh
man going outside off the mic to do this
like on time would if I wore it under my
clothes well I've seen spider-man in the
hoodie before ok the audience will get
here it would suck if you just like
swerved off the road right now this is a
really narrow little stretch of road
[Music]
I've already money oh gosh yeah I don't
know how it's going to come across in
the video there's just clouds like the
the trees just stayed on one thing
there's a forceful sarcastic pedantic
the world
guys let's climb this what this super
steep thing of rocks I just easy to
write mine - come on go ahead you got it
see you later guys ok I'm going to go on
an adventure
[Music]
yeah I'm going to get lost in the woods
and die it'll be great as close to a
mirror so they told us to bring a beanie
hat I didn't have one so I brought this
I guess I might publish it you know ha
ha ha
takes me hold the camera for a bit
Lancer okay hey Sarge crew doesn't down
brother foldable
Saunders to cortisone Erica regionalism
ding dude to do is take pictures of like
the amount amount
look I'm Matt from super veteran place
here
I think we'll provide on a diet took a
video in here like hey you have my
hatchet okay so no way my mom was just
really a tribal my mom was really
paranoid about me coming out of here to
this alone so she gave me a bunch of
stuff that the school doesn't know I
brought flip this over so I could
including a hatchet and some stuff to
start a fire and some trash bags and
[ __ ] to make a tent I don't think I'll
need any of it something in there but I
have it anyway just just in case taking
pictures yeah thanks but uh doggy
side in the camera guy are you talking
well you learn in the camera son oh yeah
one huh boy we're going to get murdered
by a Bigfoot or a rake or bump in the
hatchet when I go crazy from height I'm
going to keep close eye on that hatchet
it's an established weapon now it'll
show up in act 3 3 plus there's another
one too
so here you see there and what are the
odds you eat it could be a [ __ ] word
like I need to work I got a dollar
we're gonna do a prank oh yeah I do a
prank prank okay I don't so what do we
get you just innately kind of prank I
[Laughter]
print the vlogging Oh what I'll dive in
and it won't have any negative
repercussions but through it all like
pull me in that one spot what the [ __ ]
is that a chemical truck yeah it's
probably coming
that's the bubble oh thanks you're the
one who passed chemistry by one point
and I think I got the extra point on
that test the past just because the
teacher felt pity on me contest timber
to its negative one point hey Ron go
subscribe to Hannah's Channel what does
it in your feature boxes
to that
you're an afro here wise Michael Behe
thanks for telling me where that
spiderweb looks hairy that'll be great
for the video my briefcase
that's a lot nerd I know what's up it's
David now we are all victims to the
silent killer
right so tooth decay my package was
supposed to get here today
hi bosz the nerd box and just one thing
popping my package wasn't Sanjana your
Apple yes
what a big farm guy on his package
wasn't like a Pandora's box
so I called ups and they got so mad cuz
they said they'd dump it off you know
more more MORE edit I just I checked
under my under my door and it's under
the mat again they did set my package
perfect put it on hello that'll be a fun
shot if you send me go they don't think
right hey as long as we can see the
teacher we're not going to die out here
unless the teacher gets lost as well hey
where's the future hey what you got you
got the Nerds in your yeah just a hell
yeah what is either why'd you dump them
out because the bodies are closed
Xavier rinky teacher yeah
it's a fan point war movie everyone look
out yeah Idaho it's not good David
I'm even a fall and die man they need to
be playing like an MGMT song over this
the hell is this fights truck have a
hole in it oh okay
hey what's up you doing here how you
doing you should make it use a kiss I
had a birthday so good are you doing
okay you guys can't put this on YouTube
video
how's the height thing buddy Oh nervous
I'm so lonely terrifying it was a porch
on a piano like damn it you do good in
David's car out there alright we can
distract the monster with those yes
there's a monster with this bottom
Austria oh yeah all right breaking the
found footage horror movie rules
[ __ ] I could be at home reading
comic books right now instead I mean
having to enjoy all this [ __ ] nature
I'm pissed
got it let's go hang on come on yo yo yo
what's up YouTube mister the countdown
for Eddie
Keenan come on go it goes we're gonna
get eaten by god oh my god to go through
me people sometimes when their cannibal
goes you don't even want to know what a
mullah station course does
[Applause]
mm sit down son homework what is this I
guess yeah yeah yeah
and we're like like the outdoor
Breakfast Club okay inspirational quotes
if it's David you just like shot don't
have your legs on the on the ground Eva
can it do you live under the bridge and
make people pay a toll they'll go
through we're just past I got it oh no
my bridge has crabs time to put it down
well you could just get some special
bridge shampoo it's time to put it down
how long do you think thick to wash that
whole thing again come on I like nerds
do we do it in the bridge Castro's
neural lattice enemies it's how it fends
off predator songs you got any in you're
going to cut one another feeling there's
very fine
you got a catch in your mouth you all
right ready did you catch it
we're getting close keep your stumble
ready the 20 is you very close you can't
see them nerds see you son earth today
you're a pocket
let me killed someone down that rock
rolled and being but I'm just really a
party I am the bridge crap sorry you
mustn't see fit
yeah kill them kill the crap he'll the
crab and eat its nerds notes on pieces
I'm sorry gravity Bridge fight all right
this is it
I should be acting what are you doing
like this right I get up there yeah
not hard don't think even better but
Weaver gotta find it wait what's over
there who's blonde huh
I gotta see I gotta film oh that's cool
whatever it is bender what are you doing
up there oh [ __ ] this what you do sister
found feet the found-footage monster
hides in here
yeah the crab the fridge crab seriously
what the [ __ ] is that it's cool man you
find all kinds of neat [ __ ] in the
fourth it reads that way probably is
there no like handle on the door it's
all expected huh uncle they probably
don't have a hand on the door because of
people like us yeah walk up and start
banging on the door you would totally go
exploring in there we're so stupid I'll
put a William axe I would I would I was
offering to hang out the bridge a second
ago by your neck yeah I'm other M
spider-man hashtag dogs products I love
dogs as well mrs. bridge Krab there is
afraid
Oh
creo que es muy importante para la salud
Camila toka scarabeus todos los días
future take point no habla English wow
thank you
hi miss that first day it almost looks
fake like it's just like it just looks
like a backdrop I know this one thing
like you can just fall over
no that's what's great it looked like it
was like something like one plush it
like it fall over
looks kind of flat from this angle
magical matte paintings are a good idea
hi boys just are finished / - what
number three reading calm and morning
because we were talking about being
awake versus being
I sweep but not like you know like
metaphorically yeah you get out of it
huh once you get out of the readings
okay whoa
one-way procedure yeah that's how they
do
and I remember exhibit it looking to
kind of see society hell if there's a
glown car I am watching you mister car
give me all your secrets okay
I'm zoomed in so far that every micro
motion of my hand makes the camera jerk
like 20 feet to the other direction I
want to zoom in and just see like that a
bridge yeah it's a rotor fish oh damn I
wanted to see a golf cart riding up the
side of the mountain around its me son
beanie look that's without beanie put
intellectual maybe we're like we're
going up now so that's nice because uh
this is the audience the roof there's a
hotel up here it's a bit burned down I
think another thing oh yes - oh sure
Hotel kids that's where the
found-footage Monster is the real
question is we got stuck on here up here
are we gonna get first uh-uh
John ya gon have my mouth moving that's
true I honestly don't know how people do
this yeah I don't know they don't
usually use that big a camera no people
people vlog on DSLRs all the time Oh be
careful
oh my god I'm fine whatever your theater
don't blow me you're making me shake the
camera now get my arms tired
all right let's keep going gang all
right let's split up and search for club
I thought you died in watch me hey look
there's the bridge with the crab well a
good thing we've brought like rain stuff
right everyone know I brought a trash
bag with holes in it
cuz I'm poor I'm gonna rain and this is
it activated noise it means that the
chief attention Oh guys the teacher
calling that we don't have much food you
gotta go look in the nature I've heard
the surface I've heard that if you look
high in trees then this one sometimes
you'll find things the Bears and other
small creatures have overlooked I don't
see anything
oh hey strawberries all vertex will be
good for a week well I tried that too oh
you knew this heading up there we're
gonna head to the Train guys do you want
to hop on the side of it Rob the Train
with me hey wait let's go let's go well
you could do it
sprint go faster he's gonna die out here
or paths you hit Sam we borrow boys
rattle snake Gulch rad guys I'm gonna
name my new metal album rattle snake
Gulch you in hand which Millicent yeah
I'm streaming this on the internet and
what side what everywhere yeah yeah
what's up everyone I'm going to film
inside of an airport and get angry when
people act like it's weird people does
it say how the thing burned down and I
you want a nice finish Dalton how did it
burn down so what's different oh man I'm
tired
it looks fine on it sometimes people are
you look at you're [ __ ] fired the
hell this side you know I think we
should do pull down our campus
absolutely we need to sacrifice a virgin
in here Sean come over here since iron I
beat you to that joke yeah I knew if I
didn't get on that right Sean I told you
I'm great I know it's hard mentally
using your recordings aver nice first
time no I under a lot
wow there's not a whole lot left of this
hotel you guys is that all that survived
good god that must have been some fire
the irony that the only thing that did
not burn was the fireplace I'm going to
climb in we're going to climb in as
partners Godzilla Meadows not what if
you're getting tested
okay you're a banana you're really close
to let me tell her middle name Godzilla
no pain panorama what are they doing now
I just had lunch
well you got well what's uh what I
didn't go into the launch pad launch pad
what the whole come on Xavier you have
to bloggers encounter phone
oh my vomit that you I only actually I
still got like 20 minutes here hold this
don't eat it or if you do you know just
save some for me okay
this is precarious what's happening why
am I going along with it I'm being super
careful you don't even know
or why my do dumb [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
dick or
hey what if we can't climb backs up up
there okay
it's down that get yeah what what is
that the launchpad I'll just film from
here so idle your easy okay yeah oh yeah
look we're going to get in trouble
oh you know more trash can I collect
that come on Josh something the crab is
she's not getting at me you came out for
a second you decide with it alright I'm
going back up alright
this run okay just walk back super easy
I can do that's easy
Wow
tower the branch Hey look everyone I'm
Nathan Drake I'm holding on to a rock ah
III just tumble all the way they did
with the rebel they died they got killed
by a Bigfoot your feet are pretty big
this is so those China's is a listening
post that was given as you ever look huh
probably maybe I want to sit on that
bench I'm gonna sit on that bench on the
high let's go here neurogenesis mighty
yeah goes on forever
my name is Dirk rock path
what and I killed terrorism want to race
down I agree
like a little scratching
you [ __ ] daddy hey I think that's
David's car
oh the [ __ ] I saw this from way over
there I hiked all the way up here just
so there would be no more spots left to
sit that's great son [ __ ] Rock I know
you need to channel cuz they love to
fall outside here you go father who
lives there and there and Eisenmann and
they're very bad very fair night for
this e1 and when he died I suddenly
realized oh thank him at all but for the
things he did I cried because you would
never do them again I'm going up there
you got go upside down this is such a
mess they pulled into class every way oh
you got it easy do it and I'll teach you
you would do it then again answer right
there okay yeah let's go I can was gonna
die okay hey where you going on this
footage there you go you got to land
lower super : yeah you go
you want to be my vlog going up on now
you got to get a buck so uh that day's
over we're about to head back down the
mountain
it's amazingly beautiful here hey it's
been funny you're going to get our
unique water
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm annoyed that my phone camera has a
better camera than my camera camera make
that up
Oh God I haven't gotten to that point
yet I'm not that poor yet I'll do vlogs
when it's really bad gotta focus on luck
you're right I should start doing blog